donald trump jr
who is just
desperate for his father to like him
just desperate for his father to like
him
he posted what are essentially dick pics
of his dad
um
look at this image we're putting up on
the screen for you and no it's not
x-rated
um
sort of i guess like making fun of the
redactions in the affidavit that was
released related to the raid on
mar-a-lago
jr put out on instagram
an image of an obese trump on the golf
course
with
a redaction over what would be very
large genitals
suggesting that you would need such a
redaction if trump's
pants were off i mean listen to what
these people are doing to the country
they're laughing at us around the world
in his desperation for his dad to like
him don jr
did a fake dick pic meme suggesting his
dad is extraordinarily well endowed
would the tagline redact this
and the way that this is written up
in different news outlets it's nobody
even knows how to cover this stuff
donald trump jr
posts obscene meme
about his father's crotch
junior responded to the release of the
heavily redacted affidavit that provided
justification for the search of
mar-a-lago by posting a meme on his
instagram of trump
with a comically large
black bar
over his crotch
redacted
trump jr captioned the photo oh my god
the meme follows similarly solicitous
comments from arizona's republican
gubernatorial candidate kerry lake who
recently said that trump and desantis
have bde also known as big
d i have to be careful for our radio
affiliates big d energy
trump made the same claim about his own
genitalia during a 2016 republican
primary debate when rubio
made a crack about the size of trump's
hands
uh stormy daniels reports trump has an
unusual penis
guys what the hell is happening
uh huffington post don jr posts a quote
dick pic of dad
after affidavit release
quote redact this
always the intellectual donald trump jr
on friday came up with an innovative way
to respond to the public release of the
affidavit posted a picture of trump and
his golf duds with a long black bar over
his crotch
this is listen folks
the right loves to say
isn't this great these are just like
normal people like me and you
most normal people wouldn't do this
a lot of people if they were posting
this type of stuff they might lose their
job so it's actually very much not like
you and me at least i i've never posted
pictures like this to the internet let
me put it that way
so that's the latest there
just an incredible incredible incredible
humiliating situation